this was an evening called Brits to
watch and what they saw was one Brit
owning her first Hollywood red carpet
just like the young up-and-coming
British TV and movie talent the couple's
here to showcase Kate's Royal role is
also in its youth and she could have
been doing it for years
stars of the silver screen and those who
funded Robin shoulders with the best of
British a welcome breath of fresh air
and I mean talk about flying the flag hi
it can't go any higher great news she's
handled everything so perfectly with
such dignity and she's so she's so and
easy with her smiles when she needs
people William and Kate now the biggest
stars in the world and I think the
impact they've had on Hollywood which
houses the biggest stars in the world
shows you that they are working the room
inside William that Barbara
and Kate pants then from the blaster
president and future king a speech
before I start I just like to thank
Colin Firth for my perfect opening line
I have a voice
the Americans are hearing him loud and
clear making it across the pond had
always been in the script and it's taken
them just two days Paul Harrison Sky
News Hollywood